the government bailed out Wall Street
executives homeowners and struggling
auto companies but what about the rest
of America I uh I thought it would be a
great way to save for our daughters
college for you only get married once so
I threw myself a Sex in the City
bachelorette party and bought manoa is
for all of my bridesmaids all 12 of them
this African businessman sent me an
email over the Internet to my work
account saying that he had an exciting
business opportunity for the both of us
he said his name was open way from
nigeria in train man it is a money
sucker I thought Susan Lucci was a lock
for another Daytime Emmy he had been
years all I had to do was wiring $50,000
into an American account and then might
get sixty percent of the inheritance
didn't think twice about giving him my
Sosh and then I had to fulfill one of my
dreams as a bride and have k-fed at my
bachelorette party which was amazing I
still get chills from it but that was
another 30 grand which is actually a
pretty good deal because he usually
costs more to make up for it I quit my
job and under the world series of poker
but an injury prevented me from
competing I hangovers an injury turns
out it was a scam where's my bailout
where's my bailout so where's my bailout
contact your congressional
representatives and ask them where's my
bailout because all Americans should be
protected from their own stupidity